hey youtubers is charlie big Game of
Thrones news happening this week so
they're having the tcas George R Martin
already talked about his delay for a
Windsor winter that was the big news
earlier this week but now the big news
is that they're finishing discussions
for season seven and eight and HBO is
still trying to get more out of Dan and
Dave and the other really awesome thing
is they confirm the premiere date Game
of Thrones season 6 episode 1 will be on
April 24th of this year just bumped by a
couple weeks normally it would be that
first week in April
but the vinyl series is pushing into
April just by a little bit so just
giving a little bit of breathing room
still happening in April so everybody
breathe a sigh of relief
what HBO brass like what the you know
the big important people at HBO are
saying is that they're finishing
negotiations for season 7 & 8 and as
much as they want 10 seasons of Game of
Thrones Dan and Dave said they're
feeling like they said earlier in the
year at the Emmys that they feel like
eight seasons is all they have left in
them mostly I think that's a creative
thing you know in terms of story
material from the story that they're
doing obviously there's a lot more in
George RR Martin's books but because of
what they put out and the pace they're
moving at they just they feel like eight
seasons is where they're gonna hit that
end point but it has taken him over a
year to figure out a contract for season
7 & 8 for all the actors everyone
involved then I wouldn't plan on season
8 being the absolute last season of Game
of Thrones until season 8 finishes
airing so bare minimum what we're
looking at here is two more years of
Game of Thrones after this year what
about the spin-off George R Martin has a
bunch of shows in development at HBO one
of them he said is super secret and he
can't talk about that might be a game of
Thrones spin-off the weird thing about
HBO when it bought the rights to do the
Game of Thrones A Song of Ice and Fire
series is that I believe that their deal
only included the Maine Song of Ice and
Fire novels so we're just talking about
the Maine novels I'm assuming that
doesn't include duncan egg or any other
books the george RR martin might write
inside that universe there is a book
called fire and blood that George R
Martin is planning on writing but not
for a long time not till he finishes
dream of spring and it would be a
retelling of the complete history of the
Targaryen family it'd be like if he
rewrote Song of Ice and Fire in all the
other novels just from the perspective
of the Targaryen but given the amount of
time it's taken him to finish wins a
winner I wouldn't plan on seeing that
book before 2020 Game of Thrones
HBO series will be a long done by the
time he
ready to write that book so H Bills
comment about season seven and eight
really didn't include any specific
spin-off talk but I think that they
would probably just wait to talk about a
spinoff if they were developing one
which I think that they are till we get
closer to season eight I don't think
there's a lot of incentive for them to
do a spin-off series right now like
while you just have the main series it's
this really precious commodity and if
you know that you're gonna be getting
this other thing then suddenly the main
show seems a little bit less precious
what does that mean for the plot of A
Song of Ice and Fire because you know a
lot a lot of season six is extrapolated
from stuff that they think that George R
Martin is doing they haven't read wins a
winner they haven't read dream of spring
but they probably have an idea for where
the characters are headed so big
signposts that we can point to and we
know they're gonna have to address at a
certain point the war for the dawn
what's going on with mysterious
character that's coming back what's he
gonna do when he comes back when is
Daenerys going to bring her dragons in
her army to Westeros and what is going
to happen in the south what is going to
happen in King's Landing who will take
over the realm and rule in the ashes of
the war for the dawn
I think it's been to the TV shows
benefit that it doesn't try to do every
single thing from the books it doesn't
get too sprawling which actually is one
of the criticisms of George R Martin is
that his books have gotten so big that
it becomes a problem for him to wrap up
storylines now some people say the show
makes it way too simple and that is a
fair criticism but I think based on the
characters the show is introduced in the
directions that it's taken them it'll be
much easier for them to wrap up their
narrative in a satisfying way it also
doesn't hurt that since the very
beginning of book 1 they keep repeating
the line winter is coming
war is coming there was a little bit of
drama on Twitter this morning you may
have seen the author of the Outlander
books they do a series on starch based
on the Outlander books also somewhat
side fantasy genre took a shot at George
r Martin by saying that she is not going
to let the series pass her books what
she actually said is that she's not
going to pull a george RR martin and
just not write whenever she travels if
you've never heard George R Martin's
process he has like a very specific
process for how he writes books it's
been very successful so you know I'm not
gonna criticize it unless you're a more
popular writer than George art Martin I
feel like you can't criticize him JK
Rowling can criticize George R Martin
all she wants all other authors unless
Kien rises from the grave to criticize
George our Martin cannot criticize
George but I wasn't sitting in the
audience I'm sure she's going to
apologize soon like oh I'm sorry I
didn't mean to make fun of George our
Martin I'm just saying that I'm not
going to let my series pass my books so
no need to send her hate mail or
anything like that but if you haven't
been watching Outlander
Black Jack that one of the big villains
from that series is actually Edmure
Tully from Game of Thrones which is
probably why we haven't seen ed Muir for
a while I know there's a lot of rumors
that we're gonna see the blackfish again
during season six so I'll be really
excited to go back to the Riverlands but
even if this show circles back around to
Riverrun and we get blackfish I don't
think that guarantees that we'll see ed
Muir I don't know if he's going to be
guest starring this season but here's my
big question for you guys let me know in
the comments so jump forward a year till
the end of season seven of Game of
Thrones
if HBO is able to get a couple more
seasons out of Dan and Dave like say
okay we're gonna make it an even tenth
what additional things do you want them
to do from the books but I think what
happened in that scenario is they would
still try to keep a big season long war
for the dawn you know White Walkers
versus the armies of man in a single
season so they would push that to season
ten instead of doing it in season eight
but then you have to replace that in
season eight in season nine with
something else so I think probably the
easiest way to do that is to you know
maybe introduce one or two additional
characters you cut out you know maybe
like a young Griff type character and
then just go deeper into the characters
you already have spend more time on
character development one of the biggest
problems with the show with a cast that
big Game of Thrones has one of the
biggest casts ever on television is the
use can't spend time with every single
person as much as others so what you've
seen happen over the last five seasons
is that the show has its main cast and
it has its supporting characters the
main casts get the most screen time just
imagine spending more time in Dorne with
the Martell characters imagine more
flashbacks to Robert's rebellion there
are all kinds of things they can do to
add to the narrative without getting too
bloated and it slightly related news I
know some of you are asking me if
Natalie Dormer spoiled Game of Thrones
Season six are part of Game of Thrones
season 6 which you went on Jimmy Kimmel
not technically we kind of have a pretty
good idea of what's happening in season
six they're really just looping back
around and grabbing book plots that they
didn't do in previous seasons
so really the surprises that I'm
expecting or just the scale like what
things actually
look like you know how crazy it actually
gets like you know XYZ characters are
all going to meet in a place do a big
thing you just don't know how crazy it's
gonna look or what's gonna happen after
it so no I'm not really too worried
about spoilers or anything like that
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Nathan beard you win a $20 Amazon
gift card please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I get your
contact details and there is a new round
of the giveaway starting now all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video if there's anything you guys
really want me to do for next week's
game of Thrones video just let me know
in the comments if you guys don't know
what's going on with the winds of winter
delay you can click here for that video
it's my giant game of Thrones Season 6
playlist with all my videos and you can
click here for the brand teaser that HBO
just dropped thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you